At the end of the previous video, we ended up the following iteration.
We proposed reduced feature set that uses only
the most influential features on interselection time of Starburst.
We then evaluated how well that new updated model worked out.
We were able to refine our model to address the overfitting issue.
However the linear regression model we chose clearly was not
capturing the spikiness of the behavior that we observed.
We can use the diagram depiction of the history of our analysis to
more rigorously identify options forward.
We might continue using linear regression.
And return to the feature selection stage.
We initially chose the complete set of interselection times.
Then used the reduced set.
We can revisit this phase by including terms of higher order thus making it
a polynomial regression.
Alternatively we could attempt to represent the regression estimator with
a different model altogether.
Specifically we might try neural networks or kernel density estimation.
We might find that producing a point estimator is too high a level of
precision altogether to be supported by the data we have, and
instead try to recast as a different statistical inference problem.
For example, we can conduct a hypothesis test for
interselection times between Starbursts and Airheads.
To provide a degree of confidence that they are not of the same popularity.
The thing to notice is, because we've kept track of the decisions we've made
along the way, we're able to easily identify new possible paths.